okay let's see where you're at with
understanding the
path know there's three identifying
marks of iido three
you're if you're not doing these three
you're not doing
Ika
okay who can name them or one of
them reconciling
no Tak
Taki okay so it is the
reconciliation of iido form with iido
nonform okay that's the third one that I
list form H the first one be form no
koku and II
no koku and II are internal aspects
right so do you mean the that like the
the skill in K and II so skill in the
internal aspects of the art okay okay
that's number two okay so if
you if you do not gain that skill you're
not doing iido okay so meaning you can
do you can do uh iido as any jiujitsu
you can do it externally it's not I
some jiujitsu they're all
external okay but iido has an internal
aspect to
it what the first one and the most
important one non contestation no nonc
contestation is an identifying Mark of
all
jiujitsu all Jiu-Jitsu have non-c
contestation and in fact every single
martial art has non-c contestation right
even even um
e even the military Arts okay there's a
mitigation of risk it's only the the
civilian who has the fantasy of
overwhelming with Superior Firepower do
you see that it's always better to have
Superior Firepower but to use it in a
way that you mitigate risk that is much
better use of superior Firepower do you
get it so for example uh
I have I have tanks uh and I can charge
up this beach against all of your uh
forces and stuff but it would be much
better if I flank you with these tanks
do you see that and
so even in that context you mitigate for
the reduction of risk okay so that's
non-c contestation is how you mitigate
for the reduction of risk it's it's only
the fantasy uh of video game mentalities
that that you keep resetting and
that denying the reality that people are
dying cuz you keep freaking trying to
overpower someone do do you understand
that so non-c contestation is is really
just a marshal strategy but it is a mark
of all
Jiu-Jitsu okay so iido does have non-c
contestation because it is a Jiu-Jitsu
in it um it does do it externally but it
also and predominantly does it
internally through iki and Ki
okay well then first one is the mystical
State okay skill
in gaining and maintaining the mystical
State what is that what is that okay
well it is what has been spoken about
for centuries throughout the the history
of human beings across cultures okay so
in modern terms uh we are going to say
that it is the ability at will
regardless of environment or
circumstances to
deconstruct the what we call the first
mind aspect so that ego tripartite when
you do that what we call the second mind
aspect kicks in that is the mystical
state it it what is it it's not the
first mind aspect it's not dich it's not
fear right it's not preference and
avoidance it's just
is there's
no sense
of the subject object dichotomy because
there's one more dichotomy that goes
away is not I don't move the sword the
sword
moved
okay so again the three marks of this
art is the mystical
state
skill and koku and II and
Takami skill and koku and iiki require
the first mind aspect to be
deconstructed you can't you cannot do
it you can talk about it but you can't
do it or you can make it now external
for it's all about
leverage but that's not it and takus is
the same thing you cannot do the
reconciliation of form and non form from
the first mind aspect it cannot
happen you can't do forms at the speed
of life in combat the form just
is so towards the cultivation of these
markers we do all kinds of practices in
the
dojo that are aim towards the
deconstruction of the first mind aspect
the deconstruction the cessation of the
the ego
tripartite so we have
etiquette we have the Sensei Desi
relationship we have meditation we have
service servitude practices do you
see we uphold the virtues of
humility and
Valor Faith do you
see and we culturally shame
Pride
fear all forms of disengagement
retreating
cowardice right if you think about it
we're not like
loser but a glance from me when you did
it is enough to
go no do you understand it's it's a sh
it's a it's a an old tool of cultivating
virtue in human beings so you you have
to have both the lesson and
the negative lesson so shame is what you
call
that but we also have some some very
what your mind wants to see almost
different from all those other
practices um what your mind wants to see
is very direct ways of gaining koku and
I or takam musu I because they they'll
work on the technical things okay but
I'm telling you you you'll better off
you you're better
off prioritizing these other
practices because they go deeper because
they have less allowance for
deviation
than working on technical
things but our technical curriculum is
lined up towards these three markers
okay and they are the following you have
to have Kon
waza Kon waza is a
ritual where everyone does their
prescribed role it is pure prescription
but it's prescription in those three
markers do you see so it's not any kind
of ritual it's an as if ritual you're
going to do the technique as
if you have access to the mystical State
as if you have C and II and as if it is
a Reconciliation of form and
nonform from there we have micr Drilling
micro drilling we're going to take
segments or sections out of the kihon
waza to focusing on those parts only but
we're doing it for the purposes of those
three
markers so for
example in the last
class they're trying to check our hip as
we're going from clearing the guard to
side control
right and your ego tripartite wants to
push back on what's pushing on
you you cannot
deconstructed you in an antagonistic
relationship with the person that you're
trying to control because you're trying
to control
them so what we did is we just pulled
that part out and we said let's see you
releas
release from this
antagonism toward what then toward
deconstructing the ego tripartite and
getting yourself out of this dichotomous
reality we just focused on
that with the with the goal as I
said if you're doing it right an
observer would never know that they
pushed on me do you remember that
you you don't you wouldn't see it
because I never contested it you would
think he's letting me
by you see those are micro dropes but
they're aim towards these three
markers the next level because you're
moving towards those three markers so
for example you're moving towards
takam the next level is what I have
landed on calling
intensified
Kona it's something different than the
first
one in the first one it's an as if
ritual intensified kihon waza is really
a a kind of
guaza where you don't really have a Naga
and a UK although you will recognize the
nag UK rolles from the K Raza but you
don't really have a nag and a
UK you have one person who is
trying to knock the other person out of
being able to do the
form and that other person is trying to
knock the other person out of being able
to do the
form it is in a way a kind of
competition but you can only compete
with the two sides of the form do you
understand okay
so some of the ways it comes up at first
is you're going to increase the speed
and the strength of the moves okay but
you're going to find that when you get
with someone skilled that can actually
do the farm um you're going to need
these other aspects you're going to need
that mystical State you're going to need
the II and CQ do you get it because
you'll just lose over and over and over
again so again to summarize you're both
competing against each other but with
the form with the goal of knocking the
other one out of the form okay and this
this requires that you start freeing
yourself from the form
and that is going to
require that your first mind aspect is
deconstructed okay some other things
come
up that don't come up in kihon waza if
you're doing kihon waza
incorrectly
so when you're in the second mind
aspect there cannot be fearing
you
okay and so there should not be
contestation in you because that's a
fear response do you
understand well as we do now an overt
competition if I was already in a fear
state in Kona and I was already
contesting because I was existing
dichotomously this is really going to
trigger you okay and you're going to see
the downside
and the inability of the first mind
aspect to
function at speed of Life levels at
combat
engagement in combat engagement
environments it just can't function okay
it's always behind it's always early
it's always too far in it's always too
far out do you see and all those are
openings for the other person as they
would be for an opponent or an attacker
okay
if you're doing it right just like kihon
waza you'll be in the mystical State
you'll be in a kind of ecstatic
State there's a there's a pleasure to
it just like any time in the mystical
state is it's it will
become difficult
and it should be to want to come out of
it because the whole world makes sense
from there even
this chaotic environment of someone
trying to hit me with a stick okay and
you may get hit with the stick but you
won't experience that the same way but
if you're in the first mind aspect
getting hit with a stick is going to
continue to trigger the first mind
aspect and you will only get hit with a
stick
more this is how intensified kihon was
it works
okay when this happens you can't get out
of the first mind aspect when that
happens in intensified Kona
training you should be motivated to go
back to
Kona and start looking more for for
these three
aspects this Takami aspect this internal
aspect and this cessation of the first
mind aspect the ego tripartite
okay um not all of us are
there obviously okay so you always
generally you don't do intensified kihon
waza for a long time and some people
there's no point in doing it okay
because they're just so far still with
as if rituals okay but I think our two
Advanced people here can do it without
killing you and you'll see that that
would have killed
me and then we can use it to observe
ourselves uh through this lens that I
just laid out for you do you do you
understand
um you'll also come to learn some
Marshall strategies and uh tactics that
aren't in not as readily visible in the
Kon okay so for example uh a beginner
mistake without any combat experience is
you always try to rush your
moves but when you're competing against
someone you get more juice out of
slow down their
moves okay so as you rush your move you
don't preoccupy me with
your previous move and I'm faster you
get as the opponent so for example in
the Mak to you do it half F Kitt is
coming way faster than you can do the
technique do you get it or another one
uh angle of
deflections uh
always appear to
work you see because we always imagine
that we're strong enough to do it but in
in weapons work angle of deflections are
too slow they're way too slow it's not
just that you if as I always say if
you're strong enough it'll work it but
there's always like as Weapons aren't
involved
okay so you're going to find out that
your your angle deflections just they
don't work not only because they might
not be strong enough once someone is
trying to knock you out of the
form but they will always be too slow
they're always too slow okay you're also
going to
see um that the positioning and weight
distribution of your body is not as
arbitrary as you once thought it was
because it will
delay between the moves
okay and if you can't do your attack in
the middle of my attack you're not doing
your attack the other guy is going to
knock you out of the form okay now you
shouldn't let the word
intensified only mean power and speed it
doesn't mean that so as for example if I
slow your move down enough I don't have
to move that fast do you get it and if I
am trying to move faster than you I
might not slow your move down at all and
then in terms of relative speed I'm
faster than you you see so I wouldn't go
with uh just trying to speed up on power
uh it's all about good technique
okay so let's uh let me just demonstrate
and you'll see I'm not going my athletic
fastest because it's still a training
environment after intensified Kona we
have
play and then you also have Gaza okay
and Gaza has become over time itself
very ritualized but that's
Kona in Gaza it's like you do you I do
me do you get it's not you run at me
like this and then I do these three or
four moves that's not guaza okay that's
just Kon waza done without breaks
between the Reps that's it's not Gua
okay gu means freedom so it's free
technique you do you I do me got it so
after intensifying kihan we still have
play and we still have Gaza moving us
into uh
Takami okay so intensified Kon is still
a ritualized so to speak training
environment got it um so that's why you
are restricted to defeat with the form
and not be defeated with the form so if
you start going off the rails that is
we're going to you're not you can't do
it it won't do what it needs to do okay
all right so I'll demonstrate
some okay so we're we're again we're
going to now take we did the AI ritual
of Kor and we did an embryonic so I came
here he came there and then I came here
and some of the things you're going to
notice is you see there's an angle of
deflection in there did you see it so I
came here boom and again that's not
going to
work so I had to get rid of the angle
deflection that's why I called that
embryonic because that's not Maia tush
okay so I do the
move
and I'll give you some of the mind that
I that I'm thinking okay um in my mind I
I want to be offense like I'm not never
I'm not going to trade blows with him
okay um but obviously he took a strike
and I took a strike but in my mind I'm
shutting him down you get it from the
start okay so as you I'll do a different
mindset you see how I went
backwards
instead I'm going for
in and I smother his strip before it
comes
out and you can see the timing too I the
ski is hitting him right as he's nearing
the end of the atos do you get it so he
he can't get out of it so this this
would be uh
incorrect he's coming up he's going to
count
okay
um let's start there let's go you can
see I'm not going full speed but it's
intensify okay
go
okay so we'll watch you keep
going
okay so she she got enough of the subba
and it knocked the sword into rain's leg
rain cut her leg off okay so you you
have to reconcile that atos on the first
one here we go and you try to keep doing
that okay and then but there's a gap
after the atosha and the ski so you're
waiting like he
do you get it you're going to reconcile
that was you drop your Center in the
ukemi and you're trying to get up and
get out
okay A little better but the first L
suck and you could have got her on that
sword
better keep going you try to get her
with the sword by free
it
good she got you do you understand she
rain got you okay cuz you moved in too
far you moved into the into her
mind got your leg again you could have
stood up on the end
okay good okay so we'll watch again
we'll watch this one this good just the
same thing he he's he's keeping the
offense
the sword never gets out you see it's
shut down right at his
Source
good we'll switch
rolls and so you see there's no tou okay
she's rushing the
ski and the mine got stuck on the sword
on his cut came do you see do you
understand did you got she looked at it
even she looked at the sword and your
mind got stuck on the
sword okay but slow is it so I can't
slow down like like keihan do you
understand you can just take advantage
of
it
good
he's beating her on the on the uh on the
attack okay so your your instinct
because your dichotomus is to uh speed
up your
makos do you get it but and again that's
incorrect slow down his K so you have to
increase the first to okay
good and the mine has to be fluid it
can't be stuck on the
increased better but he's still not
being checked out cuz you're you're
slurring to the
ski and you're you're counting coup
you're sh you're you're taring you're
tagging shark fins okay there that ski
is not going to hurt anyone cuz you're
just doing your
arms
hey look at me I'm the threat yes you
see I hit you okay so my my mind is is
is already on I'm not doing
fors
you see so try to try to observe uh how
my body mind changes okay talking here
this first my aspect talking here
talking here talking here and you'll
you'll feel it she'll feel it
too
so you see there was no there's noou
okay so I don't have to take a c do you
get it I'm just sitting there okay so
we'll
switch ke and I have to take em because
I have a prescribed rule in in in tensy
kihan I only take ukemi to reconcile you
and Y if you don't have enough y that
does it's
reconciled
right not
[Music]
here intact to seven you see you see see
it you want to go fast but that's
wrong Go Go full okay T to s
you understand okay so I'm going to let
her pass
that same exact thing you
see I'll let pass this
[Music]
one so just like if I'm here and I'm
going to fight you I want that fist to
be fast
[Music]
okay you see can H you with my hand
you understand but it's not
this do you see
that and then she's not taking your
KY cuz she has to I mean because she's
prescribed it's because she has
to that's intensify
okay